- One important way that
teachers can enhance
a growth mindset is to
really help students
self-reflect on their own learning.
So in the LearnStorm
activities we try to be
really intentional about
creating a lot of room
for students to engage in self-reflection.
And one of our goals in doing that was to
really kind of help teachers create that
really self-reflective environment
and really get the school
year started that way.
And hopefully that's
something that can then be
carried forward for the
rest of the school year.
It can be really easy to
learn a bunch of stuff
and not realize that you're learning it
in the absence of self-reflection.
And self-reflection can
really help us recognize
what we're doing, can help us connect it
to why we're doing it.
It can really help us internalize
more deeply certain ideas.
When teachers help students
reflect on their own learning,
they can think about
well, what are the goals
they have for their learning?
And then as they're going through
and accomplishing those goals,
if students are self-reflecting on that
and they're seeing
those goals as a part of
being on a growth trajectory,
it'll help them get to
whether it's a good grade
or becoming a better writer,
or a better mathematician.
That's ultimately more
motivating for students
and it really helps them
see, really see that they're
making progress on that trajectory,
which is a lot more motivating
then just kind of taking
off things that don't
really seem to be that
related to each other.
I think one particularly important kind of
self-reflection is when
students hear teachers,
or hear themselves, or hear their peers
self-reflect on the ways that
struggles have helped them improve.
It can be a really good
reminder that struggles
aren't kind of the endpoint of something.
A struggle doesn't mean
that you should give up
and that you're not cut
out to do something,
but to the contrary, if
we use the right kinds
of strategies and we persist
and maybe if we get help from others,
we can overcome strategies
and become better learners
or better mathematicians
or better at whatever,
better skateboarders,
better at whatever the task might be.